the prosecution and Pence will try to
paint Mike Pence as vice president as a
sort of honorable man being put under
pressure by this demonic Force as Donald
Trump I don't think that's going to
convince a lot of people Mike Pence
sucked up to Donald Trump for four years
in the most olly Engineers manner
possible
and now he wants to be president but
he's on three percent in the polls I
don't quite get what he's thinking as to
whether this will flip the script to him
because Trump's support is around 35 to
40 percent of the party now or people
that vote Republican that's not going to
change it doesn't there's nothing that
seems to be shifting that